- [Voiceover] "A circle has a
circumference of 10 pi feet.
"An arc, X, in this circle has
"a central angle of 260 degrees.
"What is the length of X?"
So let's just visualize
what's going on here.
So we have a circle, I can't
draw a circle that well,
but you get the point.
So that's our circle, this
is the center of our circle.
It has a circumference of 10 pi feet,
so if we were to go all
the way around the circle
this, it has a circumference of 10 pi,
10 pi feet.
Now you have an arc, X.
You have an arc X in this
circle that has a central angle
of 260 degrees.
So let's think about, so 260 degrees,
so if you go straight up that's,
that would, let's see if you go this far
it would be 90 degrees, 180 degrees,
if you were to go all the
way here you get to 270,
so it's gonna be right around,
and we're just gonna
approximate, right around there.
So that would be a central angle of 260,
260 degrees.
And this is the arc,
this is arc, let me do
this in a different color.
Let me do it in purple.
So this is arc X, right over here,
and we wanna figure out its length.
Well, think about it this way,
its central angle is 260 degrees,
what's the central angle
of the circumference?
Well the circumference is
going all the way around.
So if you're going all the way around
that is 360 degrees.
360 degrees.
So the fraction that this, that arc X is,
the length of X is of
the entire circumference,
that's gonna be the same fraction
that its central angle is of 360 degrees.
So once again, the entire circumference
is 10 pi feet, 10 pi feet,
that's the circumference.
Now the fraction of that circumference,
that's going to be arc X,
that's gonna be the fraction that 200,
that's gonna be the same
fraction of the central angle
of that arc relative to the central angle
if you were to go all the way around,
which would be 360 degrees.
So it'll be 260/360
of the circumference.
So what's that going to be?
Well let's see, we can
simplify this a little bit.
We could, if we divide the numerator
and the denominator by 10,
10 divided by 10 is one.
And let me make it,
actually let me just write it this way.
So we could write this as 260 times 10 pi
is going to be 2600 pi
over 360,
over 360.
And now we just need to simplify.
If we divide the numerator
and the denominator by 10
this is going to be 260,
this is going to be 36.
If we divide the numerator
and the denominator by,
let's see, it seems like they
are both divisible by four.
260 divided by four is
going to be, let's see,
200 divided by four is 50,
60 divided by four is 15,
15 plus (mumbling) is gonna be 65.
So let me do this in a different color.
This is gonna be 65.
And then 36 divided by four is nine.
And just so you see I didn't,
I was trying to do it in my head
and it's good to get
some practice doing that,
but all I did is divided
both the numerator
and the denominator by four.
Four goes into 260, four
goes into 26 six times,
six times four is 24,
subtract, you get a two,
bring down that zero, four
goes into 20 five times,
five times four is 20.
So that's all I did there.
So it's 65 pi over nine,
and it looks like that's about
as simplified as I'm gonna get,
and that's nice, because
that's one of the choices
right over here.